every morning sanumaya bista collects
water from these centuries old stone
taps in dhobigat a suburb of kathmandu
once a week water is also piped into her
home but it's barely enough for her
family's needs
many people come here and wait in line
to collect water it's never empty it's
crowded in the mornings some people come
as early as 3am
across the road women paid to use pond
water to wash clothes
kathmandu's rapidly growing population
is straining the city's already
overwhelmed municipal water system
most people have to buy water from
tankers at high
prices the city relies on aquifers fed
by monsoon rains
but as it expands and demand for water
rises they're running dry
kathmandu is home to 4 million people
the city requires 430 million liters of
water a day less than half that demand
is being supplied residents hope the
ambitious and long delayed melancholy
water supply project to pipe water from
the river to the city will reduce demand
that project is run by the public
utility kukl that's now upgrading
infrastructure to protect water supplies
from the melamchi river
the target of our kukl company is to
distribute the available water
equitably
and without
minimum without more leakages you see as
a network of kathmandu valley is old
more than 100 years so there is a lot of
problem of leakage water leakage that is
why also we are
shifting from old network to new network
which are undergoing now organizations
like smartpani are also seeking
solutions to the city's water shortages
there are very many schools in kathmandu
valley which are struggling to manage
water and provide safe water to their
kids you know so that's why we work with
public schools where there is a dire
need of water and support them with an
alternate resource of water by
harvesting the rain water that is
falling on their own rooftop we're just
filtering it and ensuring that it can be
reused unpredictable monsoon rains and a
rapidly growing city are clearly big
challenges here but many hope that by
conserving water they'll at least start
to reduce them ramyata limbu al-jazeera
kathmandu